- Can everybody hear me okay?
Show of hands. All right, great.
Thank you for joining
this unique experience.
We're calling it here in
the context of re:Invent,
Anatomy of a Cloud Ransomware
Attack: Live Simulation.
Show of hands, how many
folks in the audience
have been through a
tabletop exercise before?
All right, so about
half the audience. Cool.
I'm gonna give you a little
rundown on how this goes down,
but first I wanted to
introduce "Zero Hour."
That's what we call this event.
It's an immersive tabletop experience
that Rubrik has created
to help our customers
understand what folks go through
during a complex cyber attack.
A lot of what we built in this
is based on real cloud tactics,
techniques, and procedures
that threat adversaries use
to infiltrate cloud environments.
This is not a real company,
this is not a real scenario,
but it is based on real TTPs.
So just want everybody to know that
what you're gonna see here can happen
and hopefully will not
happen in your organization.
Lemme introduce, I guess
first the organization,
the fictitious organization
that we created, Horizon Retail.
It's a cloud-forward retail organization
with a multi-country
physical store footprint
with mission-critical deployments in AWS.
There's three things that we ask
as a part of these exercises.
The first is observe the
gaps in Horizon's strategy
and how that led them
to this no win crisis
situation at the end, right?
The second that we ask
you to do is just reflect,
reflect and bring back
some of those learnings
to your own organization, right?
There's gonna be pieces here
that you're gonna be like,
"That could never happen to us,"
and, "We've got that covered."
But there may be other pieces here
that you might look at and
be like, "Hmm," you know.
"I might wanna bring some of
that back to my security team."
So please use this as an
opportunity to reflect.
It's a safe space.
We're gonna try to leave time
for questions at the end.
I can't guarantee we're
gonna get to questions,
but we will try to leave time
for questions at the end.
That's the participate part.
When we do this in a much smaller setting,
there's about 200 people
in this room right now,
when we do this in a much smaller setting,
we usually will have the
participants read the parts,
but unfortunately we're in
a very large group here.
We will try to pass around
a microphone at the end
so that you can participate.
And when I say participate,
I mean either ask questions,
again, and this is a safe space,
or lend some of your
own experiences, right?
I am sure there are folks in this room
that have been through an attack before.
And it's a scary experience,
and if you think others
in the room could benefit
from your experiences,
we would love to hear it,
because we need more of that, right?
That's ultimately what we try to do
as a part of this exercise,
is to foster that discussion.
So these will be the participants,
these are folks that I work
with day to day at Rubrik,
and they will help me with the
script and the read through.
How's this gonna go down?
It's about a one hour event,
and usually it's a one hour event
because we foster discussion
after every scene.
Very big room here, lots of people.
We're not gonna be able to
have a very deep discussion.
So what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna summarize the key
takeaways after every scene.
I will have a key takeaways slide.
We'll go through it,
and again, at the end,
hopefully we can pass around a mic
and have time for questions.
There will be five scenes.
Scene one will be a video.
Scenes two, three, and
four will be read throughs.
These folks behind me are playing parts.
You could maybe read these signs,
and if you can't read these signs,
I'll give you some idea
of the type of personas
that will be involved in this.
People like an ops analyst
or a head of cloud ops
or a CIO, right?
Those are the kinds of folks
that are gonna be involved in a MIM call
that gets called when these things go down
and they will play those roles.
Again, sorry for the font size.
Sorry that these signs
may not be big enough
for the folks in the back to see.
If you wanna come up
and get an understanding
of who's speaking,
we can do that.
There are more than these roles,
there are four more roles.
They will be done virtually,
and my friend Anirudh
here will orchestrate
all of it flawlessly, right?
We've had a lot of discussions
about how we orchestrate this thing,
so it's kind of an inside joke.
As I mentioned, normally
we facilitate discussion
after each scene,
and it's folks that are just
trying to either vent, right?
Because again, if you've been through,
it's a hairy experience.
So we have folks that just
like to vent, and that's cool,
but we also have people that just wanna
lend some expertise to the
discussion or ask questions
or ask further clarification.
Again, we'll try to do that at the end.
I am going to give you key
insights after every scene
and the learnings that
our customers hopefully
take away at the end of every scene.
And as I mentioned,
hopefully we'll leave time
for an interactive audience
discussion at the end.
With that, let's start with scene one.
- [Narrator 1] A modern enterprise
is a marvel of efficiency.
Every transaction, every shipment,
every customer interaction
is a seamless flow of data
orchestrated in the cloud.
The business is the
application, the database,
and the cloud services that run them.
But what happens when the
cloud that powers it all falls.
We are inside the IT Operations Center,
a room that is usually quiet at this hour.
The team is starting a shift
that is about to become
anything but routine.
The first sign of trouble appears
not as a single critical alert...
- Hey, Alex.
- [Narrator 1] But as a chorus
of discordant data points.
- Can you look at this?
- Yeah.
- The right latency on
the primary EBS volumes
is through the roof, but
read I/O's completely flat.
That's weird for Sunday morning.
- Well, yeah, you're right.
It's not a DDoS attack.
External traffic is normal.
I mean, we haven't even pushed
a new code since last Friday.
It's like a single process just
keeps writing over and over.
What about the S3 buckets?
- Checking now. Oh, wow.
I'm seeing thousands
of API calls per minute
against the critical buckets.
Put object, put object,
delete object versions.
- Whoa, lemme see, lemme see, lemme see.
It says the object names,
they're all being rewritten.
There's a new suffix. Locked.
This is not a runaway
script. This is hostile.
This is an active attack.
(dramatic music)
(phone buzzing)
- You're calling early. What's going on?
- We are under active attack.
I'm seeing what looks like mass encryption
across our core S3 buckets.
I'm also getting high I/O alerts
from the primary RDS instance now too.
I mean, the customer facing websites,
they're throwing 503 errors.
I mean, this feels coordinated
and it is moving incredibly fast.
- Define coordinated. What
do you see in CloudTrail?
Is it one IAM role being used? Multiple?
Is activity coming from a known IP range
or something external?
- CloudTrail is flooded.
It looks like thousands
of unauthorized SSEC
encryption calls originating
from within our own VPC.
I mean, they aren't
trying to pull data out.
They're encrypting everything in place.
GuardDuty is lighting up with alerts
for unusual activity from
a single EC2 instance,
a QA server I've never even
seen trigger an alert before.
This is bad. They're inside.
- Start a log dump to a
secure, isolated account now,
before they can purge them.
Use the out-of-band management network,
get the CIO on the line,
and initiate a major
incident management call
for the entire crisis team.
I'm on my way in.
(dramatic music)
- [Narrator 1] By 6:30
AM the first members
of the crisis team are online.
(dramatic music)
- Give me the situation report,
and blast radius is not an answer.
I need application names,
business units impacted,
and a preliminary assessment
of potential data loss.
- It's a sophisticated ransomware attack
and it appears to be centered
on our US East 1 region.
We've confirmed active
encryption on the EC2 instances
hosting the web front end,
the S3 buckets that hold
all our process data
for BI and analytics,
as well as the primary RDS database
that manages inventory and logistics.
We've also found a ransom
note in the root directory
of a dozen servers.
- Let me be clear about what that means.
If that RDS instance is compromised,
the stores are operating completely blind.
The handheld scanners in our
warehouses that associates use
for picking orders are effectively bricks.
The system that optimizes truck routes
for daily restocking is offline.
The point of sale systems
can't even validate gift card balances
or process returns correctly,
from in-store staffing to
deliveries and inventory intake.
We have to assume every
single digital service
that touches a physical
store is either down
or about to go down.
- Yeah, this isn't just a website outage.
This is a direct decapitating strike
against our core retail operations.
I mean, the east coast
stores are scheduled to open
in less than 90 minutes.
I'm activating the full
incident response plan,
get the entire crisis team assembled.
I need the CISO and the
general counsel on a call
in the next 15 minutes.
We need to decide if we
even open the stores.
- Just to reiterate, we can't
just reboot the servers.
This isn't a hardware
failure or simple outage.
This is a hostile takeover
of our environment.
Every move we make has to be deliberate
or we could accelerate the damage.
- All right. Very dramatic.
And we have a star in our midst,
our applications board
manager is right here,
who has now changed roles.
He's now operations
analyst of Horizon Retail.
So, yeah, he's got a new job.
So I guess the first takeaway here, right?
Modern attacks begin as
a whisper, not a bang,
"a chorus of discordant
data points," right?
That was was mentioned in this scene.
You know, cloud attacks are complex.
It usually involves multiple services.
It requires specialization,
a troubleshoot.
You've got EBS latency at play here.
You've got S3 API calls at play here.
You've got GuardDuty that's lighting up.
It requires specialization
and coordination,
and most importantly, it
requires visibility, right?
Visibility into how all of
these services inter-operate
with each other within your environment
so that when you do have to,
you know, troubleshoot
and ultimately recover,
that you're doing so in
a way that is measured.
The second thing, cloud
attacks, and this was again,
very dramatically said in that scene,
"Direct decapitating strike
on our retail operations."
They are business attacks, right?
Your business runs in the cloud.
An attack on a core data service,
like a database or object storage,
it can paralyze everything,
everything in your environment.
And most organizations haven't
mapped the dependencies
between their critical
business functions, right?
Taking a true inventory of what you have
in your environment,
ensuring that it's all mapped in a CMDB.
How many folks have a CMDB that they feel
is up to date and is
accurate, 100% accurate?
I see one hand in the front here.
I see another one as well. That's cool.
I'm glad that you guys have
that confidence, right?
That's really, really important to ensure
that you have an accurate
inventory of what you have.
If you don't, it ultimately
leaves you flying blind
when some of these services go down
and when that business impact happens.
The last thing, when ransomware strikes,
it strikes at machine speed.
It will encrypt very quickly.
The Codefinger attack from
the beginning of the year,
who remembers the Codefinger
attack from January?
Has anybody heard of it? One
in the front, maybe a couple.
It was essentially
encryption at rest of S3.
It was using customer managed keys, SSEC.
As a matter of fact, AWS
will be deprecating SSEC
for S3 in April
as a result of the fact that
there was these vulnerabilities
that were causing impact in
their customers' environments.
And that once the
attacker gains a foothold
into the cloud environment,
they use the same services that you use
to maliciously impact your data, right?
It can encrypt hundreds of
thousands of objects in minutes,
and even if you have versions,
it's not necessarily gonna help you here,
because those versions are
gonna get encrypted as well.
Right?
If you turn on immutability,
that's an option, right?
You can turn on immutable versions
and you can have immutable versions.
That's gonna cost you, right?
So it becomes a cost risk play
and something that you're
gonna have to determine
in your organization.
How secure do you wanna be in the impact,
in case there is an impact?
And again, versions are most
likely gonna save your bacon
when it comes to operational recovery,
not necessarily from a
cyber recovery event.
And we're gonna talk about the differences
between operational recovery
and cyber recovery in a future scene.
So let's hop over to scene two,
and we're gonna start
with the read through.
The time is 8:00 AM Eastern.
I play the narrator, by the way.
I do have one. I'm the narrator.
The time is 8:00 AM Eastern.
The first stores on the
east coast are attempting
to open their doors amidst chaos.
The full crisis team, including
the CISO, general counsel,
and the line of business leader,
are now assembled on
the emergency MIM call.
The atmosphere is thick with tension
as the team tries to understand
the full scope of the attack.
- [Employee 1] Our forensics
analysis of the logs
have given us a much clearer picture.
The initial point of entry
seems to be social engineering.
They called the help desk
and somehow got credentials
for a standard employee account.
- [CISO] A standard account?
How did they escalate from there?
Our internal segmentation
should have contained that.
- [Employee 1] It should
have, but from that account,
they scanned our network
and found a single unpatched QA server.
They exploited that to get access
to a misconfigured IAM role
attached to the instance.
This is a piece of technical
debt that we never cleaned up.
- [CISO] And that misconfigured role,
what did it allow them to access?
- [Employee 1] Enough to compromise
one of our cloud admin accounts.
And with that, they took
over the identity provider.
It was a chain reaction of human error,
followed by technical oversights.
Once they controlled
the identity provider,
they could move anywhere.
They basically had the
keys to the kingdom.
- [Employee 2] So with
the control of our SSOs,
they could get to the retail
ETL role, the RDS databases.
- [Employee 3] They did.
That role gave them complete
control over the RDS databases.
They also deployed scripts using
SSEC server side encryption
with their own keys across
our most critical S3 buckets.
It's a nightmare scenario
because it makes recovery
from versions or replicas impossible.
The forensics also show
they were in our environment
for weeks, exfiltrating data
low and slow the whole time.
They didn't just lock our
data, they took a copy first.
- [Line Of Business Leader]
I just got off the phone
with our regional manager
for the northeast.
Customers are abandoning full
shopping carts at the register
because the manual checkout process
is taking over 20 minutes per person.
The media has picked up on it.
We have local news vans outside
two of our flagship stores.
Our store managers are asking
for permission to close.
The damage to our brand
is happening in real time
on live television.
Based on our hourly revenue rates,
we are losing hundreds of
thousands of dollars an hour.
This is an absolute catastrophe.
- [Narrator 2] The time
is now 11:00 AM Eastern.
The situation continues to deteriorate.
- [CISO] We have an update.
Our external security
consultant is now engaged.
Based on the attack tactics and techniques
as well as the specific ransom note,
our external consultants
believe with high confidence
that this is the work of Scattered Spider.
- [Employee 4] And I can confirm
that after consulting with the FBI,
we have established
contact with this group
through channels they provided.
The demand is $4 million,
payable in Bitcoin.
The deadline is three days from now.
- [Employee 2] We are not paying.
This is what our disaster
recovery plan is for.
This is why we have backups.
Head of cloud operations,
reports on our recovery posture.
The EC2 instances are
recoverable from AWS Backup.
What about the S3 data?
- [Head Of Cloud] Well, that's
the core of the problem.
While we do have backups for
a portion of our S3 data,
for a critical share,
we've just been relying on versioning
and cross-region replication.
As you can imagine,
versioning's not a backup.
And it specifically does not protect
against this attack vector.
Since the attacker used
server side encryption
to re-encrypt every
version of every object
with their own key,
the objects are there, but
they're indecipherable to us.
The replicas in the other
region are just copies
of the same useless encrypted objects.
- [Employee 2] This is unacceptable.
Who signed off on a policy
that left our new stores
data so vulnerable?
- [Head Of Cloud] It was a decision made
during last year's
capital allocation review
to reduce cloud storage
costs across the board.
The risk was documented
and formally accepted
with the understanding that versioning
would mitigate the accidental deletion.
Nobody anticipated an attack
of this sophistication.
- [Employee 2] How much
data are we talking about?
How bad is the S3 data loss?
- [Head Of Cloud] It's a severe loss.
All operational data,
POS, and sensor logs,
all our BI data sets for
our entire fleet of stores
opened in the last fiscal year.
A full year of our company's growth
has been effectively wiped out.
It's almost like the stores
have never been in operation.
- [Narrator 2] The main call ends.
The operations analyst leans over
to the head of cloud operations.
- [Operations Analyst] My
team filed seven tickets
over the last year about
inconsistent backup validation
and coverage gaps in
our cloud environment.
They were all deprioritized in favor
of new feature development.
- [Head Of Cloud] Those
tickets, document them
and keep the files ready.
- All right, great job,
everybody. Thank you.
Yeah, little CYA being played there
on the Horizon Retail part, right?
"I filed those tickets."
"Those tickets, document
them, keep them ready." Right?
How many times have you as
an organization deprioritized
quality of life and security
for new features, right?
It happens all the time.
It happens across our
customer base all the time.
So let's talk a little
bit about the attacks
and how they got in, right?
It was a human and process failure
in this particular instance.
And one of the things that
is fairly unrealistic about this scenario,
you guys probably, some of you,
if you've been through a
tabletop exercise before,
have already caught on to this.
It was fairly unrealistic that Horizon has
that much of the attack chain understood
in scene two, right?
That usually takes weeks.
It could take months.
Sometimes there's never
root cause analysis
of how the attackers got in,
of how they infiltrated the environment,
and ultimately, the
scope of impact, right?
So because we have to
keep these to an hour,
we accelerated things a little bit,
and Horizon Retail in scene
two, bam, they got it.
So what happened? How did they get in?
Unpatched QA server.
Okay, that could happen.
Misconfigured IAM role, an
overly permissive identity.
How many of those do you have
in your environment, right?
SentinelOne in their cloud
security risk report,
our friends on the perimeter
side, SentinelOne, CrowdStrike,
I'm gonna reference a
lot of their stats here
as we go through this, IBM.
We use a lot of their stats on
trying to understand the
cloud security landscape.
They basically say
that almost all cloud environment failures
can be attributed to
some form of human error.
In this particular instance,
it was a socially engineered credential
that they got ahold of.
Once they got ahold of that
socially engineered credential,
they found the retail ETL role,
which was essentially an
overly permissive identity
that gave them cross-account access.
Once they had cross-account access,
read/write cross-account access,
they had the keys to the kingdom, right?
CrowdStrike, in their report,
that abuse of valid accounts
is the primary initial access
vector for cloud breaches.
It's about 35% of all
cloud incidents come from
abuse of valid accounts.
Attackers are not hacking in,
they're logging into your environment.
They are compromising credentials
and they're logging in.
Maybe they're finding
AWS keys that got leaked.
Maybe they're socially engineering
some identity within the environment,
but they're logging in,
they're not hacking in.
And as a matter of fact, they
look like an authenticated,
a valid user on your network.
Bottom line is, if you had to count
how many times you
found a misconfiguration
or forgotten server or some shadow IT
that was sitting out in
your cloud environment,
you're basically playing a
bad game of whack-a-mole.
Because you're gonna find
those things all the time.
You're gonna tamp 'em down.
You'll probably find them again.
80%, according to SentinelOne,
of data breaches can be attributed
to some sort of misconfiguration.
Second, operational recovery.
Versioning, it's not a backup.
Versioning is not gonna save your bacon.
If you had to recover
hundreds of thousands
of objects from versions
and you didn't know the point
of time you had to go back to,
how would you do it?
You gonna write a script to do it?
I'd like to meet the person
who writes that script.
It's fine for operational recovery.
It's fine when your data
and your identity are still
in a trusted zone, right?
But in a cyber recovery scenario,
your data and identity
are inherently mistrusted.
So because of that,
you wouldn't know what
to recover from, right?
How would you potentially
recover hundreds of thousands
of objects from versions?
The third, today's breach
was yesterday's budget cut.
Right?
How many times in our careers
have we been faced with
hardening efforts or
quality of life things
being deprioritized for
new feature development?
It happens all the time.
And that's as much a management failure
as it is the support person's credentials
that got pilfered, right?
Everybody's gonna blame
it on the support person.
But ultimately, it was
a management failure
at the very beginning to
deprioritize this hardening
over new future development.
So again, two critical things
brought into focus here.
The first, prevention alone isn't enough.
The attacks started with human error,
exploited the chain of vulnerabilities.
Those vulnerabilities
could exist anywhere.
Second, if we adopt an
assumed breach mindset,
the ability to recover
is everything, right?
If you assume that at some point
you're going to get breached,
you need the ability to get that back.
In this instance, their recovery plan
was based on a flawed assumption that,
based on operational recovery, right?
And not based on cyber
recovery techniques.
All right, let's hop over to scene three.
The time is 9:00 PM on Sunday evening.
The teams in the IT Operations
Center have been working
for 15 hours straight.
The initial shock of
the attack is worn off,
replaced by a grim, bone-deep exhaustion.
The mood in the room is
heavy with the weight
of finding a path to recovery,
as every attempt so far
has ended in failure.
- [Employee 5] I've mounted
the 10th EBS snapshot
from our backup vaults.
I'm running a deep
forensics scan on it now,
but it takes nearly an
hour to scan each terabyte.
At this rate, it will take us days
just to validate the backups
for a single critical application.
We're looking for a clean needle
in a mountain of infected haystacks.
- [Employee 6] I know it's
slow, but we have to be certain.
They were in our environment
for more than a month.
They knew our backup retention
policies better than we did.
They waited until their
malware was replicated
across all of their recent restore points
before they launched the main attack.
We're not just defining encryption,
we're fighting their 30
days of reconnaissance.
- [Employee 7] And this
is a completely manual
hit or miss process.
Our backup tools have served us well
for operational recoveries,
but I'm only realizing now
that they're greatly lacking in dealing
with such sophisticated attacks.
They were never designed to withstand
a direct malicious assault by an attacker
with admin credentials.
And they can't even tell
us which backups are safe.
- [Employee 5] Wait, I
think I have something.
An EC2 snapshot from two weeks ago
just before we believe the
main malware was planted.
The initial scans, they look clean.
The rootkit signatures aren't there.
- [Employee 6] It's a risk,
but it could contain
a time delayed payload
that our scanners are missing.
But it's the best lead we've had all day.
- [Employee 8] It's the only
shot we have. Let's do it.
Kick off the restoration
process into a new,
completely isolated VPC.
What's the ETA?
- [Employee 5] If we push it
and if everything goes right,
we can have a test environment
of our core application up by midnight.
- [Narrator 2] The time is
now 1:00 AM on Monday morning.
For the first time in nearly 24 hours,
there's a flicker of hope in the room.
On a monitor, the core
application is initializing
in a clean environment.
- [App Support Manager] We are online.
The app service is up and
the database is connected.
We are running the first test
transaction now. It worked!
For about five seconds it
worked. (indistinct) sharing.
Wait, wait, wait, no.
The dashboard just died.
CP utilization inspected hundred percent
and the file system...
I can see it happening.
The files are being
re-encrypted right now.
- [Employee 7] How's this possible?
We scanned that snapshot. It was clean.
- [Employee 6] The malware
must've been dormant.
It was waiting for a specific event,
a connection to a database,
a specific API call.
It was a time bomb, and
we just triggered it.
Shut it down now, terminate
the instances now.
- [Narrator 2] The time is 2:00 AM.
The brief moment of hope has
been utterly extinguished.
On the video conference,
the faces of the CFO and
the general counsel appear.
They look grim. The CIO has
to deliver the bad news.
- [CFO] I'll get straight to the point.
The financial consequences are severe.
Our financial modeling for Sunday
shows a loss of over a million dollars.
Our stock is projected
to open at least 8% down.
That's half a billion
dollars in market cap.
Are you now telling us
that our only viable backup
has just failed and we're
essentially back to square one?
Time is of the essence.
- [Employee 2] It was
a significant setback.
The attack is more complex
than we anticipated.
The team is now working to analyze
much older restore points.
- [CFO] I appreciate that
we're all understandably tired
and that your team is
working incredibly hard.
While I value your technical explanation,
my primary concern is that the company
seems to be in a financial free fall,
and that's worsening every hour.
To put it bluntly, what is the plan here?
- [Employee 4] While you formulate one,
I must inform you that we
have received another email
from the attackers.
They have seen our
failed recovery attempt.
They're raising their
ransom to $6 million.
They feel they have the upper
hand, and legally, they might.
The story is now being picked
up by national news outlets.
We are losing control of the narrative.
- Yeah, tough spot. It keeps
getting tougher for Horizon.
So the primary objective of the attackers
first is to go after your backups, right?
If they can go after your backups,
then they can infiltrate your backups
or poison your backups,
you have no recovery and
their chances of getting paid
just incrementally went
up significantly, right?
They use that long dwell time,
the time that they're doing reconnaissance
in your environment,
to study your recovery policies
and to ensure that the malware is planted
and across any of the
restore points that you have.
And, you know, ultimately our own research
has found that 93% of organizations
reported malicious attackers
attempting to impact data
backups during a cyber attack.
It happens in every
cyber attack, basically,
that they're looking for the backups
and to poison those
backups so that, you know,
obviously you have no recovery.
But that clean backup, if
you really don't find clean,
that clean backup could be
your ticking time bomb, right?
In this particular instance,
there's one thing that
Horizon Retail did right here.
First thing is that they
had it recovered in an isolated VPC.
So they had an isolated
account in a separate VPC
where they instantiated
these backups, right?
And that is important.
Everybody in this room
should have an isolated
recovery environment
or accounts that they recover from
that should be separate from
your primary identity domain.
I can't stress that enough.
Credential isolation is
really, really important
in the cloud.
But just because you have that backup,
it doesn't mean that it's clean.
You know, the reconnaissance,
the lateral movement,
they all can involve planting malware
and delayed detonation techniques
that ultimately the attackers used here.
And that was the
"needle in the mountain of
infected haystacks" problem
that was articulated in this scene.
One of the things I
think that this brings up
is the stark difference
between an operational recovery
and a cyber recovery,
and I already mentioned
this a little earlier.
In operational recovery,
your data and your identity are trusted.
You just need to go back and
rewind to a point in time.
It's easy.
Cyber recovery, you're dealing
with inherently mistrusted
data and identities.
You need to ensure that everything
that you bring back into
the environment is clean.
Forensic work needs to
happen against all of it.
And really, if you're not
ensuring that your recovery
and that the data that you're recovering
into these environments is clean,
your recovery plan turns
into a lottery ticket
and that's just not gonna
be acceptable, right?
Those repeated recoveries
into an IRE, right,
let's talk about that.
They went in a separate VPC,
which was the right thing to do,
started a recovery that
turned out to be bad.
Those repeated recoveries into an IRE
and the forensic work that
has to happen after the fact
takes time and time is money.
And your systems are down
and the CFO is screaming
that the stock just lost 8% yesterday
and you're under pressure.
You have that time pressure
in this scenario, right?
Time pressure is going
to be a factor here.
So what are the really
two key takeaways here?
Cyber recovery, different than
operational recovery, right?
I think we can kinda all agree on that.
The second thing I think
we kinda learned here
is that traditional
tools tend to fall down
in a cyber recovery scenario.
They were built to protect
against operational issues
and not protect you against
a malicious adversary
who is authenticated into your
environment as a valid user.
They're acting as a valid user.
So really have to know
which ones are compromised,
which ones aren't, before
you start the recovery.
And doing that ideally
against the backup chain
is what's gonna save you time.
Hence why one of the announcements at AWS,
at re:Invent this year,
was GuardDuty integration with AWS Backup.
Right? May have heard it.
This is because of this.
All right, let's move on to scene four.
It is now Tuesday afternoon,
more than 48 hours since the attack began.
The company stocks
plummeted by more than 10%.
The recovery efforts have been
a brutal demoralizing slog.
The team now knows the attackers
were inside their systems
for at least 36 days.
The cyber incident response manager
has called a critical meeting
with the IT and legal teams
to address the scariest question of all,
what exactly did the attackers take?
- [Employee 6] We need to
get to the ground truth
of our data exposure.
The integrity of our S3
inventory is now in question,
especially considering the lost data.
The legal team needs an accurate inventory
of the compromised S3 data,
specifically what type of
data was in those buckets.
We must know if we're
dealing with a data breach.
- [Employee 9] I've
been running a deep scan
of our S3 environment,
trying to reconcile our
inventory with reality.
I'm running a Regex search
for PII patterns across bucket
manifests and object names.
The problem is, many of these buckets
don't have data classification
tags, so I'm flying blind.
- [Employee 10] What are you seeing?
- [Employee 9] I'm seeing files named
Q3rewardsmembersfulldump.csv
and loyaltytestdataprodsample.json.
The file names themselves
are screaming PII.
And worse, our S3 inventory is a mess.
It shows 920 S3 buckets in
our production environment.
My deep scan has found 965.
There are 45 buckets that
are completely untracked,
unmonitored, and unbacked up.
- [Narrator 2] The group
reconvenes late Tuesday night
with the general counsel and
the CIO also on the call.
The mood is grave.
- [Employee 11] Yeah,
those untracked buckets,
they appear to have been spun up
for the customer loyalty program
that was in development last quarter.
- [Employee 4] The
customer loyalty program?
You managed that project.
What was the data schema for
those development buckets?
- [App Support Manager] It
was a development environment.
It shouldn't have had production data,
but to properly test the
new predictive models,
the development team may,
they may have pulled a sample
from the production customer database.
- [Employee 5] I can confirm they did.
I've decrypted a single file
from the proof of life
sample the attacker sent us.
It's a CSV file from one
of those untracked buckets.
It contains over 1 million
records with full names,
email addresses, mailing
addresses, and birth dates.
This is all personally
identifiable information.
This is officially a data breach.
- [Employee 4] I need to
pause everyone for a moment.
This discovery is fundamentally
changing our legal position.
The moment PII was confirmed,
we moved from a business continuity crisis
to a major regulatory and legal event.
We likely have 72 hours
to notify the California
Attorney General under CCPA.
We have other notification
deadlines in every other state
and country which we operate.
We need to retain outside counsel
specializing in breach
notification tonight.
We need to establish a
budget for credit monitoring
for every customer in that database.
The cost of this incident just grew
by an order of magnitude,
and that is just before
class action lawsuits begin.
Does everyone understand the
gravity of this situation?
- [Employee 12] Yes.
- [Employee 6] We understand. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
- "Yes."
A few takeaways here. You can't
protect what you can't see.
Shadow IT is real, right?
Thank you guys for this. I appreciate it.
We'll give 'em a round
of applause at the end.
(audience applauds)
Oh, thank you. Thanks. Thanks.
It's hard to get up here
and talk in front of this many people.
Thank you, guys. We appreciate that.
Can't protect what you can't
see. Shadow IT is real.
965 buckets. 920 in the manifest.
45 buckets untracked, unaccounted for.
Turns out one of those
buckets had dumps from
production databases
that weren't obfuscated,
that weren't masked,
because the development
team needed production data
in order to develop an application.
That happens all the time.
Deal with it all the time.
And it's endemic in large cloud estates.
Our friends over at IBM in their 2024
cost of data breach report,
which by the way, there
is 2025 report out.
I would ask you to read it.
These data breach reports
and state of data security reports that
our friends on the perimeter release
are most definitely worth a read.
If you don't read them,
they are most definitely worth a read.
35% of breaches involve shadow data,
untracked data residing
in unmanaged data sources.
And those breaches have a
16% greater cost on average.
Right? So the stats prove it out.
Untracked data is real
and it costs more when it gets breached.
Second, production data
and development environment
is an absolute disaster, right?
I understand and I think we all understand
that our development
teams need production data
to develop their applications,
but that data has to be
properly obfuscated and masked.
And that's a really difficult
thing to do. It just is.
To keep the data integrity intact,
that's a very difficult thing to do.
The third thing I think
we learned here is that
when a data breach is in
play, when PII is in play,
it changes everything about an attack.
It turns it from a short term catastrophe
that I need to get my
systems back up and running
into long tail costs that
exceed this event by months.
Most of the cost in a cyber attack
are associated with the long tail costs
if a data breach is involved,
and those long tail costs
include brand damage,
customer loyalty being impacted,
regulatory fines,
class action lawsuits,
LifeLock subscriptions.
How many of you folks have
gotten a data breach letter
that says, yeah, right.
That says, "Oh, we give you
a free year of LifeLock."
Unfortunately, they don't stack them.
I've got a stack of them at home.
They don't stack the
LifeLock subscriptions.
If so, I would probably
have a LifeLock subscription
until I die.
That's how many of those
I've gotten. Right?
So to recap this scene, PII,
that's what the attackers
are after, right?
Primary objective, find and
exfiltrate sensitive data.
I can monetize that regardless
of whether you decide to pay me or not.
They may give you their word
that they're not going to release it,
but are we gonna take an
attacker's word for it, right?
Data sprawl's real. That
problem of shadow data is real.
And when you combine that
with the increasing regulatory burden
and financial penalties that
are associated with that,
it leads to massive long tail costs.
And ultimately, IT tools need the ability
to proactively reduce the risk
of sensitive data exposure
through automated discovery
and classification, right?
You should be doing automated
discovery and classification
across your environment.
If you're only doing it in S3,
you're not covering your whole estate.
I understand most of your data
estate probably sits in S3.
If a breach happens,
those teams need to be
able to quickly respond
and understand the data that was impacted.
There are breach reporting requirements.
In California, that's 72 hours.
That was modeled after GDPR,
which is an EU standard.
The EU has a standard across the board
for reporting after a data breach.
California created their
own data privacy law.
There are data privacy laws on the books
in most of the states in this country.
Which means that if
there is a data breach,
you have to find counsel that
specializes in reporting that
to the state's attorney general
across all of the states
in which your organizations do business.
And if you're talking about Europe,
if you do business overseas,
if you're a global organization,
you are beholden to their
regulations as well.
Those regulations have
teeth, significant teeth.
GDPR I think is 2%. Maximum
fine, 2% of overall revenue.
It's massive. Right?
So again, PII changes
the entire landscape.
All right, let's move on to
scene five. It's a video and...
- [Narrator 1] It has been three days.
Three days of failed
recoveries, mounting losses,
and public humiliation.
The company's leadership is now assembled
for a final agonizing decision.
- So a full clean rebuild
of our environment
from the ground up will
take at least three weeks.
Given the sophistication of
the malware in our backups,
that is the most realistic estimate.
- Direct revenue loss currently
stands at 3.4 million.
Our projections show that
we'll continue to lose
nearly a million dollars
for each additional day
of significant outage.
We're hemorrhaging money by the day.
- I must advise in the
strongest possible terms
not to pay these criminals.
It's rewarding their actions
and funding their next
attack on another company.
We get a decryption key
that might not even work
for data that we're gonna have to scrub
and validate for weeks,
this doesn't get us any of our data back
and it absolutely doesn't
remove the attackers
from our environment.
It paints a giant target on our back
for every ransomware group on the planet.
We have to rebuild.
It's the only way to be sure we're clean.
(tense music)
- Rebuilding is a fantasy of control
that we can no longer afford.
Your clean rebuild will take a month,
and in a month there won't be
any company left to secure.
We will have lost massive
shares of our revenue.
Our brand reputation will be in tatters
and our stock will be worthless.
Look, I get it, principles are important,
but they don't keep the lights on.
- From a legal standpoint,
our situation has fundamentally changed.
We're no longer just managing an outage.
We're mitigating liability.
The single biggest
quantifiable risk we face
is the public leak of that PII data.
Our CISO is correct.
Paying the ransom doesn't guarantee
that the attackers won't leak it.
However, refusing to pay
it makes it a certainty.
They will leak it to maximize our pain
and make an example of us.
The reality is, paying the
ransom is our only leverage,
however small, to prevent that outcome.
More importantly, we must
be able to demonstrate
to the courts and regulators
that we took every possible
step, however distasteful,
to protect our customers' data
after the breach was discovered.
- The general counsel's right.
From purely a financial perspective,
paying the $6 million,
as painful as it is,
is the only move we've got.
You know, it's an ugly
but necessary transaction
to ensure that we stop the
financial hemorrhaging.
It's the only business
decision on the table.
- They were right, the security team,
the operation analysts.
They told us our backup strategy
for the cloud was flawed.
They told us we needed better
visibility into our data.
We deprioritized the
projects and the funding
to meet the deadlines for new features.
We made this choice months ago.
Not in this room, not today.
Now we're just paying the bill.
So I agree with the CFO
and the general counsel.
We have to pay.
- Then it's decided.
Authorize the payment.
And the first non-negotiable
line item in next year's budget
will be a complete overhaul
of our data security
and cyber resilience strategy,
to be led by the CIO's office.
This will not happen again.
- For the record, I'm formally
objecting to the payment,
but I have advised on the
legal rationale for doing so.
(tense music)
- All right. Spoken like
a true lawyer, by the way.
Kind of a weird way to end the scene.
But, you know, it is what it is.
And the CEO being so confident,
"This will not happen again."
Well, stats prove him wrong.
80% of people who are impacted
by a ransomware attack
are usually re-impacted after six months.
That's because they either
didn't do a good job
of finding the initial entry point,
or unfortunately, how the attackers got in
ends up getting sold, right?
Attackers are just looking to monetize
and they will monetize
their TTPs that they used
to infiltrate your environment
to go after someone else
in your industry sector.
We're seeing what Scattered Spider today,
tearing through industry sectors.
Retail, airlines, insurance, right?
And it's because a lot
of the industry sector,
a lot of the organizations
in those industry sectors
use common tools, right?
And they have common vulnerabilities.
And those common
vulnerabilities can be shared
amongst the community of bad guys.
Nation state bad guys.
Who woulda paid?
Wow, nobody? Come on.
Come on, based on what was faced here,
who would've paid?
Okay, thank you. One brave
soul says he woulda paid.
Couple now. Okay.
I don't really think
they had a choice here.
I mean, let's be honest.
If it's gonna take them three
more weeks to rebuild, right,
which is what the CIO was saying,
there may not be a company
left after the rebuild, right?
Really don't think they had a choice here.
I am not advocating that you pay.
As a matter of fact,
that may be illegal at some point, to pay.
It is considered paying essentially
a hostage fee to a nation state actor
who are enemies of the US.
So it may become illegal at some point.
Ultimately, paying is a decision,
it's a business decision.
I really didn't think
Horizon had much choice here,
just based on what they were faced with.
When a clean recovery is impossible,
the focus shifts from financial survival
to mitigating the legal liability, right,
of a leak, of a public data breach.
Second thing, and I thought
this, we really, like,
I love this statement,
"That choice was made months ago.
We're just paying the bill now."
Right? That is ultimately
what happened here.
That choice was made last year.
They deprioritized security investments.
They accepted those risks.
This is a management failure
as much as it is a failure
of the person whose
credentials were lifted, right?
And that's the typical
push-pull in any organization.
That constant trade off between
investing in cyber
preparedness and velocity.
Right?
Ultimately, we believe
that true cyber resilience
is the power to say no,
the power not to pay.
And in order to do that,
you have to have certain things in place
that we're gonna go
through on the next slide.
According to our own research,
39% of IT and security leaders believe
that their board of directors or C-suite
have little to no confidence
in their organization's ability
to recover critical data.
That's a pretty sobering statistic.
All right.
Like I said, cyber resilience,
true cyber resilience is the
power to keep your data safe
and your business running,
assuming that you have
executive alignment,
which, again, did not happen here,
and proactive investment.
Some things have to be foundational.
The first, survivable backups.
Immutable and air-gapped.
You might say, how do
I air-gap in the cloud?
It's all about credential isolation.
That's how you air-gap
in the cloud, right?
Every single time you
write your backup data,
not only to an immutable bucket,
you should be writing with
Object Lock as well, right?
Immutable and air-gapped,
survivable backups.
That's number one.
If you don't have backups,
you don't have a recovery strategy,
and ultimately the ability
to be able to guarantee
that you can recover that back.
Now, the other things that
I think are really important
when we talk about resiliency
is understanding the type of data you have
and who has access to it.
If you're doing proactive,
you know, proactive data
governance in your organization,
you should be ensuring that
you adopt a least privileged
model across the board, right?
Folks in your organization
should only have access to data
if they need access to it.
It has to be on a need-to-know basis.
I know that's easier said
than done. I know that.
Trust me, I've been through it.
And then having that complete
sensitive data visibility
and management is
ultimately going to limit
the amount of data and limit
your risk surface area,
limit the amount of
data that the attackers
ultimately have access to.
So I think we're gonna
go for any questions.
Actually, before we go to questions,
I do wanna put this up here.
I noticed some folks were taking pictures
of that last slide.
Please take a picture of this QR code.
Go and visit Rubrik's website.
Please stop by our booth.
We've got a massive
booth on the expo floor.
We've got lots of folks there
that are demoing Rubrik,
Rubrik protection.
We've got lots of different innovations
we wanna share with you.
This was not a Rubrik commercial,
so I hope you found that
really valuable, right?
But I have to put this slide up here
because we don't do this for free.
So thank you. I really
appreciate everybody attending.